that's high school senior Brant Morgan  wearing number one on his jersey as he  leads his team in Jericho New York now  here's the thing a few months ago he was  relearning to walk that's because two  years ago this promising Young  quarterback found out that he had  Non-Hodgkin's lymphoma a form of cancer  multiple rounds of chemo made him weak  and even made him lose feeling in his  legs and all the way down Brant never  gave up  I'm going to do this I'm going to wake  up tomorrow I'm going to do this I'm  going to wake up the next day I'm going  to work out and I'm gonna just transform  my body back to not only where it was  but better  so Brad didn't just come back he is  Jericho's starting quarterback he still  has chemo treatments that will last  until March he says his next goal is to  ring that Bell when he's done beating  Morgan wow that was great